Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking.
I'm a cybernetic organism.
Episode of the Tim Ferriss show is brought
to you by 99 designs and ex officio.
99 designs is the world's largest online
marketplace of graphic designers and I
have used 99 designs for years including
to get cover concepts for the four hour
body, which went on to become number one
New York Times Number One Wall Street
Journal.
It was a huge hit and here's how it
works and you can check everything out
including some of my competitions.
You can see these book covers
and so on@ninetyninedesigns.com
forward slash Tim,
whether you need a logo, a car wrap,
a web design and APP, a thumbnail,
a tee shirt,
whatever.
You go to 99 designs.com you describe
your project and then within a week or
less you have tons of designers around
the world who compete for your business
and submit different ideas
and designs and drafts.
You have an original design that you
love or you pay nothing. It is fantastic.
I have used it.
I have mentioned it before,
including in the four hour work
week as a resource. Check it out,
99 designs.com forward slash
Tim and if you use that link,
you'll be able to see what
I've done on the platform.
You will also get $99
as an upgrade for free,
which will get you more designs,
more submissions. So check it out.
Ex-Officio boy, where do I begin? I
have a long history with ex-officio.
Ex-Officio makes clothing and as far
back as 2007 2008 I had a hit video that
went viral called how to travel
the world with 10 pounds or less.
And I talked about ex-officio underwear.
Ex-Officio underwear is lightweight,
ultra lightweight, quick
drying and antimicrobial.
Why is this important? Well,
I've gone through 20 plus countries
with two pairs of underwear before,
both from ex-officio, and I'm not
alone in this. This might sound crazy,
but a lot of executives, for
instance, we'll take this underwear,
they'll wash it in the sink or
somewhere else, roll it up in a towel,
like a Burrito step on it, and a few
hours later they are completely dry,
completely clean.
You don't have to just have to and yes,
they have to be comfortable
for all day wear,
but check out their clothing
as well as their underwear.
You can go to [inaudible] dot com
forward slash Tim that's x, e, x, O,
f, F, I,
C I o.com forward slash Tim and you
can see this video which has a bunch of
other packing tips,
but this underwear,
this clothing is not just
for the gents ladies.
You have choices too and they really
have an incredible collection of high
quality products that I've used for
almost 10 years now, so check them out.
Ex-Officio dot com forward slash Tim.
Hello might've seemed Munchkins.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show.
It is late at night.
I'm in Boston back on the east coast
for beautiful, beautiful fall day,
or I should say evening.
It is probably close to 1:00 AM and I
just finished up some work with build.org
if you are an entrepreneur, you got
to check them out and build that org.
But to our subject matter at hand,
Rolf Potts,
Rolf Potts Potts for off pots,
raw fox.
I'm in the Halloween spirit and a,
I'm attempting to summon Rolf Potts
to my hotel room like candy man,
but it's not working and why
would I do such a thing anyway,
I would do that because Rolf
Potts is hilarious and he is.
One of my favorite writers in this
episode showcases his intelligence and his
wits. I think one of the
quotes, for instance,
is war is God's way of
teaching Americans geography.
This guy is hilarious and he's also a
very astute observer of human nature and a
master world traveler.
Among other things.
He is the author of several books,
including vagabonding
in vagabond vagabonding.
Vagabonding has a very
important place in my life.
I sound like the the science duck
modeled after Albert Einstein.
I'm going to run with that,
but I won't subject you to that
horrible invitation for the entire bio.
So Rolf Potts road, vagabonding
vagabonding is a very
important book in my life.
It is one of two books.
The other being Walden by thorough that
I took with me when I left the U S and
ended up traveling nearly 18 months
around the world in 2004 and of course all
of those experiences set the stage
for later writing four hour workweek.
All the notes that I took and vagabonding
had a huge impact on my thinking and
how I approached all of that time.
And it was initially a four week trip.
It turned into 18 months.
So vagabonding is an incredible book,
so much so that I partnered with Ralph
very recently to produce the audio book
because it is one of my
favorite books of all time.
And you can check that out by going to
audible.com forward slash Tim's books if
you want to check that out and get
a free sample. It's an excerpt,
but longterm travel,
longterm world travel does not have
to be a wealthy person's sport.
And in this conversation we talk about
all sorts of things ranging from how to
travel, how Ralf travels
rights, wanders, gets lost,
study success studies,
quitting success or managing success.
And maybe you haven't thought that's
an important element of life planning,
but it apparently is. I've come
to believe, and I almost forgot,
of course there are a ton of resources
and links and websites and books
mentioned in this episode.
All of it can be found in
one place in the show notes,
so you just have to go to four hour
workweek.com all spelled out forward slash
podcast four hour workweek.com forward
slash podcast you can find the show notes
and resources and links for this episode
as well as every other episode like
those four Peter Teal,
Tony Robbins, Mike Shinoda,
you name it. So you don't need to
scribble furiously unless you want to.
But four hour workweek.com forward
slash podcast is where you want to go.
And uh, I had a blast with this
interview. It is a two part interview.
This is going to be part one.
And then there's part two.
And I really hope you
enjoy it as much as I did.
It was just fantastic fun.
So without further ado,
please meet Rolf Potts.
Little Ladies and gentlemen,
this is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show.
I'm very excited for this episode because
I get to catch up with a good friend
of mine who didn't start off as a
good friend. And that is Rolf Potts.
Uh, Ralph, thank you so much for making
the time. It's good to talk to you. Yeah,
and I, and I realize by saying that you
didn't start off as a good friend. It's,
it makes it sound like we might've
been arch enemies or something.
But what do you mean by that?
Is I really felt like I got
to know you through your book.
Vagabonding which was one of two books.
Uh, many people do not know this,
that I took with me around the
world for about a year and a half,
starting in late 2004,
early 2005.
It must've been 2004 and I,
it is one of my most heavily underlined
books and really acted as my guide and
my companion for all
of the various travels,
adventures and misadventures during
that time. So first and foremost,
thank you for writing such
a spectacular little tone.
My pleasure. Thank you
for reading. You know,
it occurs to me that I
heard from you in late 2005,
which was in retrospect was pretty
soon after I had written the book.
So you must've found it
pretty soon after it came out.
Yeah, I found it. I found it. Uh,
I found it soon after it came out
because, uh, I suppose in this,
this may be true for many people,
uh, the, the buying of the book,
then the reading of the book and
then the implementing of the book,
quite a bit of lag time in
between those various junctures.
And, uh, but I think like a lot of people,
I was really,
uh,
I spend a lot of time
fantasizing about travel and, uh,
taking that leap,
but had more than handful
of nebulous fear about it.
And, uh, I suppose we could
start there actually, and, uh,
naked ask very simply,
it,
what are some recommendations
that you have for people who,
who may be able to work up
the savings if necessary and,
uh,
are really just fearful of taking the
leap and exploring longterm travel.
And I suppose just wrapped into that,
you might give a brief description of
vagabonding itself and the subtitle and,
and, uh, and, and why
you wrote it. But, uh,
I'll let you explore that
multipart question if you
wouldn't, uh, wouldn't mind.
Yeah.
Well,
I liked that you bring up the idea of
fantasizing about travel because I think
it's something that everybody does
and it's one of those top three,
if not top two or one things that
people dream about that and you,
and you see it in the movies
all the time. Um, and in fact,
I mentioned this in vagabonding,
you know,
the heist movie where the whole goal
is to have this complicated, um,
robbery so they can have enough money to,
to move overseas to a wonderful place.
And as I say in the book is that you
don't need to rob a bank to do that.
In fact, you can do that
for a cost that is equal to,
and sometimes less than your cost of
living in a major American city. Uh,
and so I think an important principle
I bring up in vagabonding is saying,
don't, don't put this off if you're
dreaming about travel. And most people do.
And you know, and if you don't
run about travel, that's fine.
But I really address these travel dreams,
which are so common that don't wait until
you get to tell you're too old because,
um, you know, retirement isn't
necessarily the best time to, to, uh,
to do something like this. And
in fact, a Henry David Thoreau,
I think Walden Woods is the other
book you'd, you took on your travels.
That's right. Talks about how people,
and I'm not quoting him directly, they,
you know,
they put off what they really want to do
until they're too old to actually do it.
And you know, that's a paraphrase.
Um, and so if you're 18, 28,
38, 48, whenever you'd ring
them about travel, put,
make your goals soon and,
and don't put off those goals because
they're very attainable. And you know,
I think there's a lot of fears that are
tied in to confronting vagabonding which
you asked me if the, for the definition
it's money and as long term travel,
it's not just a vacation, it's not a
week or two off. Um, that you know,
society gives you as a vacation.
It's six months or two
years or s you know,
six weeks that you make for
yourself to travel in earnest,
not as a consumer experience, not
as a vacation, but as you know,
a more deeply meaningful life experience
and as a way to actualize your wealth
of time.
And I think this is an idea we'll come
back to a lot and it's something that you
write about as well as me
as the idea of time wealth,
the idea that your experiences are
more valuable in life. Then the,
the things that you accumulate,
then the things that are all is being
touted as the most important things in
life. So a travel is a great way
to cash in on your time wealth. Um,
and vagabonding just by definition
is a more meaningful way of travel.
It's a way of slowing down and really
discovering parts of yourself instead of
just buying a lot of experiences,
which is,
which we've sort of been conditioned
to do, uh, as American consumers.
My first vagabonding trip was
20 years ago this year. Um,
oddly enough and happy
anniversary. Thank you. Thank you.
It was just this time that I was,
that I was straggling back to Kansas
after having this amazing eight month trip
around North America and it was a
trip that I thought would be my last,
I thought I would get travel out of my
system so I could become a responsible
American workaholic and then maybe
returned to travel and I was old. But you,
you mentioned the idea of fear and
the fear is I had going out were um,
you know, is this going to
be expensive? It's going to,
is this going to be dangerous?
Am I going to come back and
be compromised professionally?
And all of those sort of turned into the,
into the opposite,
that it was a lot safer than I expected.
It was a lot cheaper than I expected.
And I came back and for 20 years had
been integrating, uh, travel, uh, with,
with a, a professional life that
continues to diversify. I continue to, to,
to do other things, to make money, uh,
while at the same time having
big swaths of time to travel.
And I'm not suggesting that
everybody needs to, you know,
become a vagabond or for a 20 year chunk.
And in some ways I travel a lot
less than I used to, um, you know,
10 or 15 years ago.
But it's something that you can do.
It's an option that you can have and it's,
it's not an APP,
an option that you wait for life
to give you, you create it. Uh,
and so I'm a big believer in the active,
uh,
aspect of vagabonding
of saving your money.
The lottery is another
metaphor I use a lot in,
in vagabonding that people keep waiting
for the lottery to reward them. Um,
but as, as we all know, the
odds that you're gonna win
the lottery is pretty low,
but we've already won the lottery.
We're born with time wealth.
And so it's just a matter of creating
these travel experiences or these time
rich experiences, uh, through
things like simplicity and a,
just the decision to make these
sort of things happen. Well, that's
one of the,
the scenes and I think gifts that you
provide in vagabonding and for those
perhaps wondering this,
the subtitle says a lot,
which is an uncommon guide to
the art of longterm world travel.
And I think uncommon in art or
both keywords in that subtitle,
uh, you provide a, a,
a portfolio, it sounds to
financial, yeah, a quiver of,
of philosophies and uh,
uh,
suggestions for simplification,
viewing the world
through a different Lens,
really decluttering your
life both materially and, uh,
emotionally and psychologically.
Even if you do not travel.
And what I've noticed is
I recommend vagabonding to
people who have no intention
of travelling or for whatever set of
circumstances feel they can't travel, uh,
simply because, uh, and uh,
I'm blanking on the
attribution here, but, uh,
I really believe that most people,
even those who have more money than
they know what to do with live lives of
quiet desperation and they have this,
they've,
they've fallen into a drone like schedule
where they have these material objects
they thought might make them happy or
give them something they were lacking
beforehand, but they've lost that, uh,
the excitement and anticipation perhaps
that they once had, you know, the, the,
the leaping into the
unknown, uh, the, the,
the feeling that kids have the night
before Christmas or the week before
Christmas and adults lose that.
Nothing.
One of the easiest ways to capture that
is to actually fantasize about travel,
but do it in detail. Right? So
not one day I want to travel,
but to read vagabonding and go, oh my
God. Like I could do a, I could be,
I could go to Japan for the first time.
I could go to Europe and Busk,
I could do all of these things that,
that rekindle,
that passion and enthusiasm
and excitement, uh,
because I think that
excitement is a much more, uh,
tangible metric for perhaps,
uh,
what other otherwise can be very
nebulous in the word successful,
right in the US. I think that,
uh, for better or for worse,
and I think perhaps for both,
we have this, uh, you know,
Protestant like work ethic towards
a relatively undefined goal,
which is this, this success. And, um,
what are some exercises just in terms
of helping to address that fear?
So you mentioned one thing
which would be setting a,
a near time horizon for
travel, right? And I,
I completely agree that the,
in many ways the utility of travel,
uh, decreases as your physical
capacity decreases, right?
So you can do the most, you
have the most options. Uh,
the younger you are when you
travel, or at least, uh, the,
the more functional your
body is when you traveled,
aside from setting a tight goal
and whether that's, you know,
a few weeks away, a few months
away, uh, what are some extra,
are there any exercises that people can
go through to decrease that fear factor
and a,
or anything they can read but besides
vagabonding to decrease that fear factor
and their, their stories, for
instance, that I'll tell folks, uh,
about, uh, Columbia is a good example.
So I recently, not too long ago,
spent a month in Midian,
Columbia,
which was formerly the murder
capital of the world, uh,
when it was under the iron fist of
Pablo Escobar, the drug kingpin.
And I,
I,
I feel more threatened on market street
in San Francisco on a daily basis
whenever I go and walk down
certain portions of market street,
then I ever felt in Midian.
And I went all throughout the entire city.
Uh, and, uh, you know, I think that
sometimes the stories can be helpful,
but do you have any recommendations for
whether it's exercises or things to read
to sort of overcome the fear
of the, the big bed, uh,
overseas adventures and all the
terrible things that await you were not?
Yeah, well add. There's a couple of
big picture ones. It, it's funny.
[inaudible] I was,
I was just there a year and a half ago
and I think now it's like the breast
augmentation capitol of the world.
Yeah. It's, it's a, yeah. You know,
South America is, it's like the CR,
I guess Korea has its facial bleaching
and then, you know, South America has a,
if you Brazil there, it's the,
the implant capitol of the world,
which is still incredible just to
even ponder. But yes, continue.
Sorry to interrupt.
Right now the drug lords moved out in,
the plastic surgeons moves in. That's it.
It's a beautiful city. But that
was just, it was a strange,
like physical attribute, um, that it's,
it's obviously a surgeons had been
hard at work, wonderful city. Um, the,
the advice is the advice
that I have. There's a couple
of a big picture ones, uh,
big picture advice that I have for this.
And one is too,
they're both sort of mental. They're
about redefining your relationship. Um,
or just how you think about things.
One is your relationship to money and
what it represents and what is your
relationship to information and what it
represents. Um, you mentioned success,
you know, the idea of the
American, uh, you know,
puritanical idea of what success is.
And money is a great metric for success,
but it's not the only metric for success.
And I think people fixate on money
to their own detriment because I met,
as I mentioned before, it doesn't take
that much money to travel. The world.
Travel isn't a consumer experience.
And I think you,
you said you weren't sure the reference,
I think you're recording throw when
you're sort of talking about these rich
people who were sort of bound
by their own riches and he's,
he's actually stealing that from
the Bible. And, and, and the,
the Old Hindu scriptures, which talk
about these, these golden chains with,
you know, under which we sink. You know,
we're bound to our possessions
and through success,
it is a very old philosophical idea.
Through success we lose perspective on,
on the good life because we tie success
so closely with money and possessions
and material splendor.
And so if you can,
if you can just redefine your
relationship with what success is,
um, and, and, and really goes
back to the idea of time, wealth,
that success is being able to do
what you want, whenever you want.
And there's billionaires out there who
are compromised in ways that you or I or
you know, you're a plumber or your
local park ranger, um, are not,
because just realizing that money is
a tool, it's not a metric for success.
It's a nice side product of success,
but it's a tool for allowing you to live
a time rich and experience rich life
and really live in ways that allow you
to not only follow but discover passions
that you never realized you had.
No, I, I, uh, I, I, I agree
on so many levels and just,
just to, because of course the, uh, we,
we both think about this stuff a lot
and I apologize for jumping in, but the,
the, just on the billionaire point to
give some concrete examples. So the,
this is very recent. I was talking to a
fellow, he is putting together an event,
it's going to be 20 or 30 people,
a number of billionaires and attendance
and it's a week long retreat of sorts.
And, and he said to me, and
this is a very, uh, this,
this actually that the
gentlemen is organizing it
is very materially successful
but actually has a very level head on
his shoulders and has been able to keep
things like time and mobility in mind
is as important currency and metrics for
his quality of life. Cc, he's done
a really good job, but he said,
of course the billionaires can't take
a week off so they're only going to be
there for 24 to 36 hours.
And I thought about that
and the billionaires
can't take a week off.
What the hell is the point of having
their billion dollars if they can't,
if they don't have the options,
if they have fewer options than I do,
if that makes sense.
And it reminded me of a conversation I
had at one point with a another person
who shall remain unnamed, but he has at
least several hundred million dollars,
maybe a billion plus.
And uh,
he was commenting on the number
of homes that he had and uh,
he's a good guy. It, but in
effect, his accumulation had,
had gotten so out of control and the ad
between six and 12 homes around the u s
and he said,
I know I no longer feel
like people work for me.
I feel like I work for them because he
has staff of five to 10 people at each of
these homes.
He's never at nine out of 10 of them.
And uh,
so he's effectively just working to pay
for homes where his staff basically are
the owners of the homes because they
live there. And I was like, wow,
it really brings to mind.
Um,
uh, this is also a quote, of
course, I don't know the, the, uh,
the attribution, but the, the,
the idea that things an excess
become their opposite, right? So, uh,
you know,
money that provides you with freedom
basically takes away your
freedom, uh, when it's, when it,
when it reaches a certain point, it
starts to reduce your freedom. Uh,
the idea that so called freedom
fighters, uh, in, in excess,
you know, given too much power,
become tyrants, right? So,
so things tend to flip when they get
to a certain point of excess. Um,
what, and, and, uh,
also just because I'm such a die hard
fan boy of vagabonding correct me if I'm
wrong, but the example that I think
you gave in vagabonding of, uh,
of sort of Hollywood nonsense related
to overseas travel was from Wall Street,
wasn't it? From Wall
Street where the, the,
the Charlie Sheen's big goal was
to save up enough money, you know,
one day when he strikes it big to,
uh,
to get a motorcycle and drive a
car across China, I think. Yeah.
And you pointed out that you could scrub
toilets and China not even in the u s
for a month or two and probably figure
out a way financially to make that
possible. Um, so certainly, I
mean, when I was traveling and,
and ultimately putting together the notes
and observations that became the four
hour work week,
I save tens of thousands of dollars
compared to simply staying in the bay area
in California. And,
uh, anyway, just a well
that's, that's the thing is that if you
live in, in an expensive city, like, like,
uh, you know, San Francisco,
New York, um, there,
there's probably a half dozen other
examples in the United States alone.
You're going to be living on
fewer dollars per day by far.
If you're traveling in Southeast Asia
or South America or the Middle East,
then you would just be paying your bills
and paying your rent and buying your
groceries at home that you're,
you're traveling in a completely
different economic zone.
Which was sort of the point of, of
pointing out this Wall Street example, uh,
in China, that was, that
movie was from the 80s.
Certainly China is more
expensive since then. Uh,
you might not have to clean toilets,
you might have to clean something else
now to ride your motorcycle across China.
But the point is, is that, uh, you know,
all this importance is placed
upon conspicuous consumption.
A romantic idea is of what we can do a,
and oftentimes it's not money that's
in the way. It's a mindset thing.
Um, which is why, um, I'm sort
of answering your question,
your earlier question in
big picture way that it's,
it's really a mindset
about your relationship to
money and your relationship
with Tim formation, which I'll get to
in a second. But you were talking about,
you know,
the billionaire who has sort of become
a slave to his own parasitical wealth.
That's an old idea too.
I have a quote from the ancient
Sanskrit scriptures in vagabonding,
which is about the king in his
palace only has half a bad and, and,
and the food on his plate for all the
grain in his fields. Does he own the rest?
You know, right. At the end
of the day, even the Kings,
and I knew this 3000 years ago,
even kings only eat one meal at a time.
They only sleep in one bed at a
time. Um, and at the end of the day,
the substance of your life
is through experience.
And if you're suddenly compromised,
your material wealth and your money is,
is there to actualize your
experience and, and um, you know,
to enhance your life meaning,
and the moment that it becomes parasitical
the moment that you're a billionaire
who has 36 hours to go to a conference.
And I'd love to know how much money
is spent flying to the conference,
catering it, you know,
because I, you know,
I know people who could travel probably
for five on what 1 billion our spins to
go to that 36 hour conference.
And I'm sure you know people
who could do the same.
So that's just such an important
thing to keep in mind is to,
I have nothing against
success or material success,
but really know where the line
is. The point at which, um,
the success you've achieved is actually
getting into the way of actualizing a,
a good and meaningful, uh,
and option filled life.
Definitely. Where does, where does
the information come in? I'm a,
I'm very curious,
have the,
the relationship to information plays
into all of this, right? Well, this is a,
this is where the, the fear factor comes
in. You were talking about Metta Gene,
you know, there's a Mexico, um, that
has a lot of drug war violence going on.
Of course, the Middle
East is a perennially, uh,
a bad reputation place to travel to.
Um,
but keep in mind that
information is something that
can work against you or work
for you. And these days,
information is everywhere. When I,
when I left to travel the
United States 20 years ago,
I was actually more afraid of the United
States then in 1994 then I'm afraid of
any place, uh, in,
in 2014 simply because their
beef pre worldwide web I had,
I didn't know what to expect.
I had no examples. I've been
in Kansas, which is not,
you know,
in sort of bullseye middleclass circles.
I didn't have a lot of friends
traveling full time. Um,
and so I didn't really have anything
to compare it to. Now if you're,
if you're a successful person
with the money to do it and,
and the physical capacity to do
it, you can go online. Uh, and,
and not only can you, can you realize
that people are traveling in Mexico,
they're traveling and Columbia,
they're traveling, uh, in,
in Egypt and Israel and other parts of
the world where you think that might be
dangerous.
You realize that there's,
there's family bloggers out there who
are traveling with five kids to these
places or traveling with
a diabetes problem or with
physical handicaps or with,
you know,
money that they've made on a job that
has a fraction of what most people make.
You know, people who have simply
decided to become wealthy in time,
regardless of the fact that they work
as park rangers or exotic dancers or
maintenance men. Um, and so
that that information you can,
if you get past,
I guess media exists in a,
in a man bites dog world,
they're going to talk about explosions
and revolutions and bad things around the
world. Um, and so much of
what we understand, in fact,
there's that famous
phrase, you know, war is,
is God's way of teaching
Americans geography.
God,
that's so horrible and so true.
And so because Americans are so NC pillar,
our international understanding is
really pegged to major world events that
don't really represent day to day life
and the towns of these towns around world.
So if you can look past the panic
driven man bites dog tenor of media and
realize that Mexico is actually a giant
country and that the drug violence is
very isolated and that
there are ways to travel in,
in a very safe way and a very
inexpensive way, then suddenly Mexico,
it becomes this amazing and
very close way to travel. My,
my sister is a college professor in
North Central Kansas and she, they, they,
she and her family took
a little, um, there's a,
a big Mexican American community in Kansas
and they just took the local Mexican
minivan now down to Fresno or Mexico
and just a family of four. And they,
they've traveled for next to nothing in
an amazing way for their teenage sons,
uh, in to, uh, to a part of the world that
people assume is full of drug violence.
Right? And, and that was just taking a
minivan from five blocks over, you know,
away from where they live.
And so that information,
realizing that the big picture news
media information is always going to be
panic driven. It's always going
to be a, you know, man bites dog.
And so the more you get to the
specific information and think, hmm,
you know, I'm, I'm 37 years old, um,
I'm looking to take a sabbatical
from my job. I live in Virginia,
uh, and I like to drink beer. Well,
within 30 minutes you can find somebody
who's from a very similar life situation,
who's doing what you're doing. Um,
and again, even if, I mean there's,
I mean there's people who
are blind who are out,
who are traveling for years at a
time. There, there are people with,
with major impediments,
uh,
and if you're able bodied and you
have a little money socked away,
there's really nothing stopping
you except your own fear,
which has sometimes tied to your ideas
of money or your ideas of what the world
is like, which is pegged
to information. Right.
Agreed. What, uh,
what type of sites or resources would
you recommend to people who are trying to
find a comparable folks?
Let's just say people who will help them
alleviate their fear of travel or just
in general, what type of online
resources do you recommend?
Um, well Google for one, I mean
if you just Google, you know,
35 year old years old, two
kids, one year of travel,
then odds are you'll find 20 blogs of
people in that demographic who are doing
just that.
So,
so really be the unabashed Ed
and very specific about googling,
you know, your fears or your demographic
and just see who like you is,
is out traveling. The world. There's
a lot of great traveler communities.
I've been affiliated with
boots and all.com, um,
since the very beginning of vagabonding.
And part of their emo is just
sort of creating community and,
and uh, and support, uh,
for people. And they have,
they have blogs and resources on their
site and there's other travel communities.
Well,
and uh, you know, you, you,
um, and boots and all is well,
we'll put the links to everything in the
show of course in the show notes, uh,
for those people listening. But, uh,
it's boots, the letter n all.com, right?
Yeah. B O t s n a l l.com. Uh, and,
and they'd been operating out of Portland,
Oregon for years and have just
quietly been doing very, this,
the nice work of a reassurance and saying,
oh, so you, so you're worried about it.
Uh, and around the world flight,
well, here's what around the house,
around the world, flights.
Look, you know, you're,
you're worried about a certain
situation, you know, here's,
here are some resources for
that. And, and they're not alone.
I'm most familiar with them because we,
we've been,
we've sort of shared a similar
mission for a long time,
but there are big
communities of travelers who,
who are happy to help and, and sort of
help new newbies feel better about these,
uh,
prospects have of longterm travel.
Yeah,
they're all over.
I remember one that was very helpful
to me in the beginning was a virtual
tourist.com and that I was with the site
for a long time and then the four hour
work week came out and I ended up becoming
friends much in the same way that I
reached out to you.
Uh,
I became friends with the founder of
virtual tourist and some now actually
involved with a site of his called trippy,
which is just trippy Dotcom as
people would expect. But, uh, it's a,
it's effectively community of,
of open questions and you can
follow specific locations, right.
So if you're interested in, whether it's
San Francisco, Buenos Iras, Spain, Midian,
whatever, all of the questions that
come up, for instance, I am just,
I'm just taking a quick
look here and you can add,
you can pose any question
you want, but, uh, you know,
what's the steepest place you've
ever been in country x, uh,
the, uh, what,
where's the best rock
climbing in San Francisco,
which is generally going to be
extremely inexpensive. You know,
what are the best online tools for
group vacation planning? So if you're,
if you're a family or multiple
families, so like you said, there,
there are many different options.
Speaking of, of technology, uh,
how have, how have, uh,
different services like,
um,
whether it's couch surfing
or even say a airbnb or,
uh,
anything else really,
these collaborative consumption
companies changed travel,
um, for you, uh, and, and, uh,
perhaps there are older examples,
but you mentioned that you're, uh,
you're taking a trip before
we started recording. Uh,
and you're doing a home
swap. Is that, is, uh,
would you mind perhaps elaborating on,
um,
how some of those options work,
those that you're familiar with?
Because I think that many people who
consider travel think in terms of one of
their main expenses being staying
in a hotel. Right. Uh, and,
uh, I'd love for you to share
any of your thoughts on that.
Yeah, well, it's shifted the way
the travel world works in, in,
in some ways that are delightfully
convenient. Uh, and, and,
and in some ways that are
a little bit strange, I,
I think that technology is one of those
double edged swords that in some ways
has turned this into insufferable
micro managers on the road.
Can you elaborate on that?
Yeah. Well, I'll, I'll start with
the negative. Um, you know, I,
I the travel culture, which I
started in, which was 20 years ago,
but really my more international traveler
travels are more like 15 years ago. Um,
it's about showing up in town and
knowing that when you get there, um,
the unexpected awaits you that you,
that you're going to walk
to the hotel district.
You may have a guidebook with
some hotel recommendations. Um,
but you're going to shop for your hotel.
You're not going to find a deal online.
You're going to walk in there,
you're going to see the room. Um,
you're going to haggle because in,
in, in all throughout Asia, you know,
basically any place outside
of the industrial world,
prices are up for grabs. And,
and,
and haggling in person is so much more,
it gives you so much more leverage and
haggling online cause you can go and look
at the room and physically
leave, uh, if the,
if the owner doesn't give you a
price that you're, that you're into.
And so these days it has become so
convenient. Not always a bad thing,
but it has become so convenient that
people just assume that the best deals to
be had are the ones online.
And then pretty soon you've locked in
your traveling for six weeks and you know
where you're sleeping
every night in advance.
And it really compromises the flexibility
of travel and the serendipity of being
inspired by a place and thinking, I'm
going to stay here for a few days. Or Wow,
I just met this traveler who told me
about this great place up in the mountains
and I'm not going to go to Varanasi.
I'm going to go up into the
Himalayas and spend my time there.
This technologically enhanced micro
managing cuts into that serendipity in a
certain way. And, and it also
connects us to home and, and again,
it's a two edge thing.
Um,
social media and the constant connectivity
that comes with smart phones for
example, allows us to really find
things that we couldn't find before.
But it cuts into the idea of wandering
around and finding things by surprise,
finding things organically and letting,
letting it get destination reveal itself
to us on his own terms instead of sort
of finding that place as a
consumer before we get there. Um,
and a lot of technologies have eliminated
things like loneliness and boredom,
which sounds good and is good to a certain
extent, but loneliness and boredom, um,
can lead you to those moments that,
that sort of force you into
a new version of yourself.
They force you to be more extroverted
day. Totally agreed. Totally agreed.
They force you to read the local
newspaper instead of, you know,
looking through your Facebook
feed. Right. Uh, uh, and so that's,
that is what we're up against with
this technological, these advances.
And I don't want to be the grumpy older
traveler because I remember being being
20 and listening to these,
you know,
baby boom era hippie sort of lectured
me on how travel used to be, you know,
back at a time when telephone answering
machines and credit cards were seen as
this decadent form of technology. Um, and,
and so I know that there are younger
travelers who don't know anything but the
constant conductivity of travel.
Um,
but unplugging is important and we can
talk more about that if, if you want.
Um, and we can also talk about the pluses
and there I have many recent examples
about how technology has have helped
this recent home home exchange.
It's just a long time friend
who lives in Brooklyn.
She's a writer and she
wants a quiet place.
I have 30 acres in Kansas and so I get
an awesome pad in Brooklyn for a week and
she gets a quiet farm in
Kansas for a time. And, uh,
the positives you mentioned or
alluded to, the positives? Um,
I I definitely want to delve into the
importance of, of disconnecting. Ah,
yeah. I think I've become somewhat, uh,
especially living in silicon valley, but,
um, have some thoughts there as
well. But what would you say,
how would you expand on the,
the recent positive, uh,
positives are positive examples.
Yeah.
Well you mentioned a Airbnb
and couch surfing. Uh,
I think in place and more expensive
places like Europe, you know,
the hostel was your go to,
it was where if you wanted to save
money and you would go to the,
to the youth hostel, um, and it
was a great place to meet people.
You get a cheap bed, you went, you,
you would forego a few amenities that
you would hang out in the hostel. Well,
I went to Amsterdam, uh,
this summer, uh, I teach,
I teach a writing course in Paris every
summer and my sister and my nephew came
and visited me and we
wanted to go see Amsterdam.
And using Airbnb,
I was able to get a full cottage,
a 15 minute train ride outside of central
Amsterdam for about half the price as
a hostel for three people
in the center of Amsterdam.
So instead of staying at, at
at somewhat grungy, hostile,
and the red light district,
um,
we were staying in this little
town filled with windmills, uh,
and we had our own house to ourselves and
we could just walk down the street and
get groceries.
And so that was an airbnb hookup.
Couchsurfing is a similar,
has similar benefits. Uh, it,
it just allows you to break out of not
only that old hotel set of assumptions,
but also out of the hostel
instead of assumptions.
The idea that the cheapest option in
any place is going to be a hostile,
especially traveling in groups. For the
three of us, if I had been alone, maybe I,
maybe the cottage, we wouldn't
have been as cheap as the hostel,
but with three of us where you're
getting hostile one bit at a time, um,
we just got the perfect place
to stay through airbnb. Uh,
and so those services
and even social media,
even going on Facebook or Twitter and,
and I'm not a big believer
of tweeting while you travel,
I think that that really puts you into
this whole mindset and it pulls you out
of the place where you are and the point
of travel is experiencing what's before
your eyes and not what's coming
across your social media feed.
But before your travel, before once
travels. I'm a big fan of throwing,
throwing out a tweet or Facebook
post that says, Hey, look, I'm,
I'm going to be in this place.
What are some suggestions?
And that is something that
didn't exist 10 years ago, uh,
and is not tied to a business or social
networking thing like Airbnb and couch
surfing.
But it could just be that your buddy from
high school has a friend who's in the
military in Germany and they have an ex
girlfriend who lives in Stockholm and
suddenly you have a place to stay,
uh, through very random circumstances.
And so that kind of,
it's,
it's the old model of sitting
in the hostel or sitting
in a guest house or a bar.
And an exotic part of the world,
talking to the six travelers who are
there with you and them giving you advice
on points further down the road.
That principle has been taken to
social media and through networking.
That's another way that technology has
allowed that, that that old hostel room,
it's actually killed the,
the literal hostel room where people
are now staring at their phones in the
hostel room.
But is it,
has expanded the virtual hostel room
where instead of talking to the six travel
or is your width physically,
you can be talking to 600 travelers
through your networks who might have some
good advice for you?
No. Agreed. And the, to touch
on the disconnection point,
uh, I think that, uh,
I think that social media and
being online while traveling,
if the objective of travel is to,
uh,
gain some introspection,
have unique experiences and come back
better than when you left in some way,
uh, is very dangerous. Uh, and at
least speaking for me personally,
uh,
the laptop is a portal to many
different things and it's,
it's very common,
at least for if I'm speaking from my
personal experience and looking at many of
my friends whose,
whose professional lives
are based on computers.
They look at a laptop that
look at their smartphone,
they look at their desktop
computer for work, which is most,
the vast majority of them, uh, who were,
who were managing email using base
camp or other online services to manage
business. It is, it is a, uh,
it's very easy to use Twitter or Facebook
socially is a gateway drug and you're
only one tab away from, from,
from going right back into your,
your old routine.
Uh,
and it's extremely easy and seductive,
like you said,
because of the convenience
to travel abroad. And I know
many people who do this,
unfortunately, uh, I don't see the
point, but they will take a laptop,
go overseas,
stay at a hotel that could just as easily
be the four seasons in any major city
in the United States. And they
come back and they really haven't.
They've changed time zones, but their
mind, their experience hasn't changed,
uh,
more than perhaps what they had
for lunch while they were abroad,
which is a real shame.
Uh, and so when, uh,
when I've taken these, uh,
when I've taken sabbaticals,
which are typically because I feel like
I need to reassess my priorities and
gain some perspective on things that are
hard to assess when you're down in the
weeds, right? When you're, when
you're deflecting bullets and,
and dodging problems and putting out
fires, looking at your email inbox,
it's very hard to step back and look
at the larger picture of your life and
goals and whatnot. From a
30,000 foot view, uh, that,
for instance, when I went to,
I went to Bali to Indonesia for
the first time and took 30 days,
uh,
off of computer phone and
a calendar basically to,
like you said,
move from the micromanaging of my daily
experience to the extreme opposite for
me at least,
which was pretty much pure
serendipity and forcing myself to,
uh, rather than feel comfortable
and convenienced, uh,
to feel as uncomfortable as possible.
Uh,
at least when you consider how
routinized life becomes this,
even if you're, especially if you're
kind of optimizing for efficiency, right?
It's very easy to become
trapped in systems of your
own making where you're like,
whoa, fantastic. My per our output is,
is wonderful and doing all these new
things I'm taking on new projects and then
you step back and you realize, wow, I
might as well just be a cyborg running,
you know,
running in all these systems.
So this is a very long meandering
observation. But I think that, uh,
even if your only goal,
and I don't think this is a crass goal,
but even if your only goal were to,
uh, improve your professional life, uh,
especially if you run your own company,
taking a month off the grid is perhaps
the best way to do it because you have to
set up systems that will
persist after you get back.
Uh, if you're taking three
days to go to Amsterdam,
you don't need to do that a week off.
You can probably come back and still
rescue things, but a month off,
completely off the grid. Um, and I was
available for emergencies via phone,
by my assistant or other people.
Um,
they had to call the office at the Bahasa
Indonesian language school and find
their way to me. Um, you
really have to I think,
think about the bigger questions that
are easy to avoid, um, by, by, uh,
keeping your hands full with
busy work. But anyway, long,
long sort of preachy observation.
But I really think that um, you know,
the, the less you feel you can
go without your smartphone,
the greater the value of
going without your smartphone.
Yeah. Well this is, this
is an old conversation. Um,
if the first person to do this in,
in the technological age was,
was actually JP Morgan. Um,
when the Telegraph was invented,
uh, he went to Egypt and
I forget exactly it was,
it was a little over a hundred years ago.
Uh,
and his companions talked
about how he was in Egypt,
but not really because he was always,
he spent his whole time in Egypt
attending to business. It was exactly,
it was like the turn of the
previous century version
of what you just explained.
It was him in a hotel room. Um, you know,
attending to his business tech technology.
Basically the Telegraph,
which is seems very primitive
in retrospect, um, prevented,
you know,
JP Morgan from actually being in Egypt,
he may as well have not left home. And so
this is an old problem in, in, in fact,
the travelers of previous generations
have complained that sailboats,
that steam ships were compromising travel
in ways that sailboats didn't isn't in,
in, in, in the Roman era. The, you know,
the technology of Rhodes was changing
the way travel was experienced.
George Orwell talked about how trains,
uh, we're changing the way that,
that travel was experienced in,
in trains.
When you think about it was a technology
that allowed you to Prabal so quickly
compared to how you previously could,
that you could maintain a business
relationship of sorts while you were
traveling. Um, I don't think there's,
there's a silver, silver bullet,
um, that can keep you from being a slave
to your smartphone when you travel.
It's hard. And as he
edit, as you mentioned,
there's some things that
you have to maintain, um,
back home if you're traveling for
more than a couple of weeks. Um,
to an extent it's a lot
about self discipline. Uh,
there's something to be said
for physically not taking
your smartphone with you,
which is something I don't do when
I travel. I use the Internet, right?
Yeah, absolutely. I make it,
I make it harder so I don't
have a data plan that, uh,
that generally allows me to get
international coverage. So I can't,
I can't use the phone.
Yeah.
And this pays off in tangible ways.
There's been recent research that having
a vacation that is actually a vacation,
and this isn't even about vagabonding,
this is about vacations is
important for your creative mind.
It's important for your brain that,
um,
having a cessation of obsessing on your
creative life will allow your brain to
work in ways that will give,
that will make you more creative.
So even if you go,
if,
if you traveled to
Amsterdam or or Bangkok or,
or the the Andes for a week and you're
constantly attached to your smart phone,
in some ways it could be less advantageous
to the creative life of your business
or your career.
And if you just let go,
because if you let go of that
constant stream to the information,
the micro managing, then your brain is
working in the same that it was back home.
And part of the gifts of travel is your
brain and your emotions and everything
is working in a new way
and your brain actually,
that obsessive part of your
brain is resting. But it's a,
it's actually working in its own way and,
and this is actually a
scientific information the
New York Times reported on in
about a week ago that you actually
come back if you can unplug,
if you're going to actually immerse
yourself in a new place and turn off that
obsessive part of Your Business Brain,
then you can come back and your
mind will gift you with, with,
with creative ideas and insights that it
didn't have if you had spent your whole
time in the Andes or Amsterdam or
Bangkok obsessing on those very business
issues. Definitely. I'm sorry
you took, you took an inhale.
You feel, it sounded like
I interrupted you. W well,
there's one more point I was going to
make is that it's sort of, it's sort of,
this ties into the idea of time,
wealth, but sometimes these days,
this new generation has a way of
stealing time wealth. Again, it's,
it's not that new, I mean,
Plato complained about that,
that written literacy was ruining people's
ability to memorize poetry. Right.
Um,
but now this technology is so,
is so immersed in our lives that we
can steal our own tongue wealth by,
by being hooked into virtual experiences
into our social media feeds instead of
the experiences that are before
us. Um, you used a great phrase,
which is optimizing for efficiency and
just think if you're going to sit down
and do it in Italian meal in Italy,
are you going to want to optimize
that meal for efficiency?
If you're going to hike for a week in,
in,
in the Andes and the Machu Picchu reason,
are you going to want to make sure that
that hike is optimized for efficiency if
you're going to be sitting on a beach,
you know, in, in, in Thailand or Brazil,
or are you going to want to optimize
that, um, experience for efficiency.
I think that that Italian meal metaphor
can apply to so much of travel that of
course you don't want to
make it more efficient.
You want to savor every bit of it. You
want to be you. We want to be, you know,
eating tomatoes that were in the
ground two nights before. And,
and having just these very sensual,
tactile experiences,
not just in not just food experiences,
but just ideas of the unexpected,
of, of unplugging yourself from the life
that you can predict the life that you
could consume and buy and stumbling into
experiences that catch you by complete
surprise. And I don't want to overuse
the idea, uh, the word super serendipity,
but it's something that is at
risk when we can unplug. And,
and the gifts of serendipity,
um, are not just, you know,
actually you can stumble into a bad
experience is as easily as you can stumble
into a good experience. But it's, it's,
it's admissive ventures or the unexpected
good experiences that actually change
you, you know, to,
to the core of your being in a way that
those preplanned experiences don't.
And so if you can't unplug,
you're robbing yourself of that
aspect of your time wealth. You're,
you're making Tito extend this metaphor.
You're making optimized efficiency out of,
at an Italian meal,
every sense of the word. Um, and
it's hard to break away from.
But in the vagabonding sense,
it's essential. You're, you know,
you're going to be selling
yourself short if you can,
if you can't stop micromanaging
and optimizing for efficiency.
And the more you think about those phrases
in the context of the best parts of
travel, um, the, the more you realize
that you really have to throw,
you know,
the jargon,
the efficiency jargon of daily life out
the window and just throw yourself open
to the travel experience.
Definitely. And what you, just,
one thing that I think about a lot and
part of my motivation for traveling
oftentimes,
and you don't have to travel a
over overseas to achieve this,
but I find the, the, the change of
scenery to be very helpful for resetting,
um, is to focus on appreciation as
opposed to achievement. And I'm,
I'm very type A,
always have been and it's competitive.
Uh, and then those can sometimes
really reinforce themselves in, uh,
in good but often
destructive ways. And, uh,
when I go abroad, I think food is a
fantastic lens, actually use, not,
not just metaphorically,
but to really focus on slow,
long meals is, I think one of the
greatest gifts you can give yourself.
And that was one of the, one of the
experiences that I brought back after my,
my nine months in Argentina,
which was supposed to be four weeks.
As these things often turn out, um, with,
with the really long dinners, you
know, a couple of bottles, wine,
a bunch of friends,
of course they have the Benicia and
the incredible meets of, of Argentina.
But,
uh,
putting aside the fact that they're
famous in South America for being
unproductive, uh, putting that aside,
uh, the, the long meals, uh, with,
with larger groups of
friends was something that I
brought back with me to the u
s and that I try to do at least once
a week or once every two weeks. Uh,
the,
the other observation I wanted to
make for folks because I really was,
well, no forget, was I think
once, once a computer addict,
always a computer addict just to kind
of borrow from Aa and once an addict,
always an addict.
And you have to manage that.
And I think one of the easiest ways
to manage that is to not rely on self
discipline. What I mean by that
is when I took my, my trip, uh,
in 2004, which, which some people know,
began with a one way ticket to
London and no planned itinerary,
no plan return date. Uh, I didn't
take my laptop. I did and I knew I,
I couldn't take my laptop because
I would default to using it.
And what that meant was at the time,
and there are many different ways to
do this now, but I had go to my PC,
installed on a computer at home,
and if I wanted to use
my laptop so to speak,
I would have to go into
an Internet cafe at which,
which is not generally one of my
favorite experiences. It's pretty deep.
They're usually dingy eight.
It's just not an experience I enjoy,
which is entirely the point.
I want it to make it inconvenient
and unpleasant to engage in a sort of
masturbatory, a computer
use, you know? And uh,
and uh,
I think that it's,
it's very easy to default to that because
you can always find something on the
Internet, right? Whether it's,
and you could very easily go to Morocco
and then end up sitting on your laptop
watching the stupidest cat videos on
youtube for hours a day. The hate,
because that's what the
Internet optimizes for.
It optimizes for clicks and views and
everything else that can be commercialized
generally speaking. So,
you know, don't even enter,
don't walk through the door if you
don't want that to happen. Um, so when,
when possible,
sort of change your environment and
remove things that facilitate bad behavior
as opposed to trying to rely on willpower,
which I think is very,
very fallible. Uh, the, uh,
you mentioned creativity.
And I wanted to,
to ask you about that because I really,
really enjoy your writing. Uh, and
I, and I don't say that lightly, uh,
not that I'm the ultimate
connoisseur in writing,
but I think that a lot of writing is
very, very bad. And I, I, uh, I, I've,
I've loved your writing and enjoyed it
for a very long time. Thanks. Of course.
Yeah, it's, it's had a huge
impact on my thinking and not,
not moreover my actual behavior
and way of living. So the,
I want to talk about the, the
concept of a staycation. Uh,
are there times, uh, for, for,
uh, creativity and let's just say
you use writing as an example. Uh,
do you find that you can replicate some
of the benefits of travel in what people
might refer to as a staycation?
Yes. Yeah. And this goes
back to something that,
that we were talking much earlier,
um,
in the conversation about
decluttering emotionally. You,
you talked about the idea of a,
I think he used the word portfolio to
describe something. Um, but I think,
I think vagabonding uh,
the principles of vagabonding
apply to life in non travel ways.
Um, and it, it's,
it's been used as a text
and social studies class and
it's sort of about another,
tying into something else you
were talking about earlier,
you were talking about something that's
sort of constitutes what some people
call it,
the beginner's mind,
which is part of the excitement of traffic
definitely is that we get stuck into
being experts and the, and, and online
resources allow us to be sort of Dillard,
[inaudible] experts in
everything. You know, we can,
we can suddenly know a little bit about
everything when in fact the beginner's
mind is,
is,
is one of the most daunting and exciting
parts of travel where you just allow
yourself to be a child again.
And in fact,
I have some quotes in vagabonding talking
about how you go to a new city and
you're as dumb as a five year old, you
know, you can hardly read. You know,
you don't know why it's dangerous
to cross the street. You know,
that this is a gift,
a of travel is that it allows you to,
to have the vulnerability
of being very young,
but also the excitement of very being
very young and the discovery of being very
young. And sometimes for all of
the research you do back home,
the coolest part of showing up in, in
Bangkok or websites or, or, you know,
Cape Town is just smelling the
place, you know, or, or, um,
or going in and into,
not into a tourist place,
but into a supermarket and realizing
how different everything is. And it's,
it's that beginner's mind. It's, if
that wonder of childhood stuff. Um,
and that can become a, it can turn into
a cheesy metaphor, but it's a real thing.
It's the, it's the beginner's mind
that allows you to engage in a new way.
And so I think that ties into the
idea of creativity and the staycation,
which is a silly word for,
for what is a great idea,
which is taking that beginner's mind,
taking that travel mindset,
which I talked about at
the end of vagabonding,
the idea of coming home and treating
your neighbors as exotic tribesmen back
home.
And one thing,
and actually one thing I'd love to talk
to you about is the idea of appreciation
versus achievement, because there's limits
to achievement. I mean, you've been,
it's been four hour work week,
came out with seven,
2007 yeah, seven years
ago. And I think there's,
you know,
there's an extent to which that ongoing
success can be as meaningless as ongoing
lack of success,
and that you have to have a relationship
with that to realize that appreciation
becomes more important than achievement
because there comes a point at which
that you've achieved your goals and
now what, you know, definitely. Um,
and so I think achievement
is a linear way of thinking,
which is very American and important.
And I'm a big believer in that.
But appreciation is that more
eastern circular way of thinking,
of being able to save or what you
do have and balancing that with your
achievements and, and so, so that goes
back and ties into the creativity,
the idea of coming back home.
And I own a house on 30 acres of land
in Kansas and that, that's no accident.
I'm close to my family, but
it's also really, really cheap.
And instead of letting it in a fashionable
part of a big city, I can, I mean,
what's happening right now as
an example of it, I'm doing a,
I'm going to go live in
Brooklyn for a week and, and,
and do a little home exchange. And
I have the option of living in, um,
for short periods of time,
anywhere while at the same time saving
money and really building a relationship
to a place which is my quiet 30 acres
in a sparsely populated part of north
central Kansas. And I am
extraordinarily creative there. Um,
not just because it's quiet,
but because I can have sort of
a quieter sense of discovery,
sort of a walking space, neighbors
pay sense of discovery, uh,
in the place where I live. Um, Eh,
this is another one of those silver
bullet things you were talking about. Um,
how you enjoyed my writing.
Um,
and it is so tortured
sometimes to write well,
you know,
that you're very familiar,
beautiful, smooth reading, logical,
inspirational paragraph with pros
is the process of a day of labor and
self-loathing.
So I just,
because I have this wonderful
place to write and, and uh, that I,
that my increased
creativity is enhanced by,
by marrying my travel mindset to my home.
Doesn't mean that I just am sitting at
my desk laughing and glee with my glass
of wine writing brilliant per
pros. Um, it doesn't get easier,
you know,
I guess it,
it enables that creative pro enables
that tortured process to be fruitful,
um, in a way that, that
perhaps it wouldn't have
been otherwise. I don't know.
I don't know.
I know that you have a very,
Annie Dillard said that his
schedule is a net for catching days.
And I think that you,
you're a believer in being
very disciplined about
having a writing schedule.
I'm not very disciplined,
but somehow it works anyway.
Well,
just,
just because I'm a believer doesn't mean
that my fantastic practitioner. Right?
But,
uh,
I think for folks who are wondering
what it's like to be a writer for most
people,
now I should maybe caveat that with the
observation that I ha I have extreme
jealousy slash anger sometimes towards
extremely good journalists who have daily
or weekly deadlines because,
um, many of them, uh,
to my, to my great upset, uh,
disagree that writer's block even exists.
And the say,
I don't have the luxury of writer's block.
I need to kick out 1500 words a day
and they're exceptionally good at it.
And it's just infuriating because my
experience with writing is number one,
it has not gotten easier. Uh,
generally people ask me like, oh,
well after the third book, you know, it
must just get easier to use. I'm like,
actually, it just gets harder
and harder because I have to,
I feel like I have to ensure that I'm
not repeating myself. Uh, but the, uh,
the,
the most accurate sort of portrayal of
my experience of writing is a adaptation.
And Oh my God. And uh, and uh, I actually,
I think Nicholas cage is
amazing in it. Um, but, uh, the
movie, the movie is weird. I,
I read the screenplay first, but just
the idea that you sit down, you're like,
okay, I'm going to do this. I'm going
to do this. And you're like, no, God,
I should really wash my face. You know,
like, I should just, she did a donut.
I need to relax before I start writing to
all of these, like, you will at least I,
you know, I'm rand, I can't, I can never
really, I don't know if it's iron or, and,
but anyway, let's just say I'm Ren,
uh, had a book called how to write,
I think it was,
how to write nonfiction.
And there was a portion
called the white tennis shoes.
And I remember the white tennis shoes
is a refers to the fact that if you sit
down to write and there's a pair of white
tennis shoes with a little blemish on
it, you will, you will convince
yourself that you need to,
you need to clean those shoes before you,
right.
And that a writer will do anything
to avoid writing. Uh, so that's,
that's my general
experience. I feel like a, a,
a schedule or at least a plan helps too.
Even if you don't fulfill that
plan. For me it's, it's done.
I think this is actually a Winston
Churchill quote where he said that, uh,
in effect, you know, a plan is important,
not because you're going to follow
the plan, but for the planning itself.
And I find that having a plan for writing
decreases my anxiety associated with
writing, which helps me to write, even
if I don't execute that plan perfectly.
Um, but, uh, what did, what did,
what is your writing process like?
And I have a, you know, some,
some additional questions
about travel of course, but,
uh, and vagabonding I
should say rather. But what,
what does your writing process look like?
When do you typically sit
down to write and why?
Uh, well, it's funny that you mentioned,
uh, the Nicholas cage character,
character and adaptation as something
you can relate to because that's like the
least glamorous depiction of a
writer, you know, and you're,
you're going to compromise people's
romantic conception of you as a writer.
And, and, and, and my process
is, is possibly even worse,
I think, because, I don't
know, I think in, I, there's,
there's different neuroses attributed
to writer and, and mine, um,
is maybe a little bit obsessive compulsive
that sometimes I could be the guy who
writes two hours before breakfast
every day. And sometimes I am,
but sometimes I'm the guy who writes
for 14 hours. Um, and, and is,
is it most fruitful at our 13? Uh, and so,
you know,
my,
if I wrote a writer's handbook and
I teach writing and I try to instill
discipline and ideas of
discipline in my students,
cause that's important because people
can over romanticize writing and think
about the muse visiting them.
And in fact,
you need to be the one who creates
this. But in practice, I'm,
I'm sort of a bad example that there's
some days we're all just sort of be just
frustrated with myself. I'll have
my spot on the white shoes problem.
I actually bought the freedom APP.
Do you know the freedom APP that
turns off the Internet connect?
Oh, the freedom APP. I thought
you said the freedom map. I
was very excited. Yes. No,
the freedom APP is cool.
I agree.
Yeah.
Uh,
and it's just one of those things where
despite my good intentions sometimes, uh,
you know, my, my,
my monkey brain goes back to the Internet
and I just have to be my own mother
and discipline myself. Um, I wrote a,
um, in 12 days earlier this month. Wow.
And so that's an example of,
it was really,
it was sort of a [inaudible] movie
screen play that I did for fun,
just because I had this
idea. And, um, I, I,
I would compromise my happiness if I
didn't suddenly write this movie that was
about design, be zombies and
giant dinosaur attacks. Um,
and I think that was almost part of
resting certain parts of my intellectual
brain. And it was just delightful
to write a really Popey story.
But it was interesting.
It's like I keep teaching myself lessons
when I wrote something low stake when I
wrote a B movie, uh, you know, uh,
a monster movie earlier this month.
Um, it gave me such an interesting
creative perspective on mine,
on my own processes and the importance
of just getting work out there, um,
that I was,
I was able to write 90 pages in 12 days,
where as sometimes I can be torture
portrait over a 1500 word article.
So I think there's something, you
know, worthy and the idea of, you know,
Anne Lamott's idea of shitty
first drafts of getting the word,
the words on the page. Kurt Vonnegut
said that there's two types of writers.
There's supers in bachelor's,
a Superbowl.
I'm so glad you're bringing this
up. Yeah. Please go into this.
You're familiar with the concept,
but I want you to,
I want you to explain
it cause this is so key.
Yeah.
Uh,
well supers tend to be people who will
blast through their first draft and then
they'll spend days,
if not weeks,
working on draft number two and number
13 and number 67 until they get it right.
Whereas bashers, um, they
go sentence by sentence, um,
and by the time page one has done then
paid, then paragraph one has been written,
rewritten 10 times. And by the time
they finish what they're working on,
be it 1500 words or 30,000 words,
it's pretty much done.
They're not going to do a whole lot of
rewrites, but that process has taken,
you know,
20 times as long as a super we'll take,
and these are both legitimate
creative, um, uh, methods and,
and he suggests that maybe women tend to
be sweepers and men tend to be bashers.
And that might be statistically true. But
I've met, you know, a male supers and,
and female bashers.
Um,
and they're both creative ways.
I am a basher through
true. I am as well. And I think, I think
of the two, I've never been a super,
so I don't know how it feels,
but I have to imagine that being a basher,
it's just the most torturous
process of self loathing and doubt.
I just, I, it's because there are days,
I don't know if you've experienced this,
but it'd be like, okay, great, I'm going
to try to knock out whatever it is,
a few pages and I will just agonize
over the first two paragraphs for in an
hour. It's, it's so god,
it's just like gives me anxiety even
thinking about it. But yeah. Anyway,
I apologize. Is this is serving
as a therapy session for me?
Oh, no, it's, it's actually an,
and hopefully people in our
audience getting can take hardiness,
but it's the exact same situation that
the last third of a story or even a book
is the easiest to write because I have
the first two thirds to show that I'm not
a complete incompetent, you know,
and that I have, I in my office,
I have different,
you know,
writing awards and articles about myself
to sort of remind me that I'm not a
completing competent,
but would that blank page
that the generations of
writers have talked about is a
real kind of anxiety. Um, and,
and getting started. And I have a,
I have a really bad combination,
which is that I'm a basher,
but I'm also an optimist.
And I,
and I think that if I completely gave
way to self loathing and pessimism that I
would just throw something
horrible out and then,
and then I would have
something. Um, but I'm just,
I just have this blank page anxiety
coupled with, with the optimism that I,
that I, that I, I think I can do good.
It just makes it that much harder
to get started because I'm a,
I just can't,
I know that something is going to be good,
but for some reason that first
step is somehow at odds with, with,
with my optimism. So it's,
it's a weird thing and I,
and I'm actually relieved to hear that
you, um, struggle with the same thing.
Oh yes. Struggles I think are
very, uh, generous light words,
especially when we were
both successful authors.
So I think that there's something,
know, hopefully people take,
take some solace in that.
Uh, the, uh, I think,
I think matters are not
helped by the fact that I've,
I've tried for years to change my writing
schedule so that I get good synthesis.
Um, I tend to differentiate
between research and,
and synthesis or gathering up all of my
material and then putting it into prose.
Uh, it doesn't help matters
that I've tried to become
a morning writer and I have
friends who do this for the wake up really
early and they kick out good pros in
the morning.
I've never been good at it.
So I tend to get started in the middle
of the night when it's pitch black
outside. And so I have those
moments of acute anxiety.
It's just I might as well be
in solitary confinement in a,
you know, in a basement. Um, so I,
that probably doesn't help my
psychological state much, but who knows,
maybe some good has come of
it. Uh, the, what are you,
what are some of your favorite
books or articles on writing itself?
Uh, or just commentary. These could
be authors who've written about it,
but I'm just, uh, I'm looking for her
for things myself quite frankly. Uh,
to read it, you mentioned Anne Lamont. I
think bird by bird is a fantastic book.
Uh, but what, what uh,
what are some of your favorite
books or commentaries on writing?
Uh, what is this funny? Because
I, I teach writing in various,
thank you for supporting the
sponsors of this show. 90 designs,
which is your one stop shop for
all things graphic design related,
go to 99 designs.com.
Forward slash Tim to see the
projects that I've put up,
including the mockups and drafts of
the book cover for the four hour body
ex-officio,
ex-officio and I go way back,
ex-officio dot com forward slash Tim you
can see the clothing that I've used for
traveling through 20 plus countries,
including the underwear. By the way,
that's about half of my
underwear drawer right now,
ex-officio dot com forward slash Tim you
can also see the viral video that I put
out, which shows you how to travel
the world with 10 pounds or less.
As always,
you can subscribe to this podcast on
iTunes and you can find all of the links
and resources from this episode as well
as every other episode by going to four
hour work week.com forward slash podcast
spell it all out or you can go to four
hour workweek.com and just click on
podcast feedback. If you have feedback,
I would love your thoughts. Anything at
all who you'd like to see on this show,
ping me on Twitter as t Ferris, that's
twitter.com forward slash t, f, e.
R. R. I. S.
S or on facebook@facebook.com forward
slash Tim Ferriss with two r's and two
s's. And until next time,
thank you for listening,
okay. Okay. Okay.